the number one tip that networkers won't  normally share with you because this is  how you really network in the real world  instead of trying to figure out some  hack or some memorization trick what you  do is you become the most valuable  person to everyone else on your network  and they will introduce you to the  people that they want to gain status  from by making the intro for example if  you're good at marketing or you're good  at selling help everyone you know at  sales and at marketing and they will  make the introductions to other people  when they come to terms because they  know that you will provide value to that  person and so they will gain status by  connecting the two of you because you'll  provide value on behalf of them and that  is how networking really works